what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
just watched our very first episode of
marvel's what if and i'm very curious to
hear what everybody thinks about this
new series from marvel the very first
animated series coming from marvel
studios let me know what you rate this
first episode 1 out of 10 and let me
know how you feel about the animated
series the first episode starts off
pretty strong i would say and it starts
off with captain carter and i have to
say that i definitely like captain
carter i like the dynamic that her and
steve have because even though steve
doesn't go on to become captain america
like in the mcu he does go on to kind of
become essentially the first iron man
and i thought it was pretty cool how
they work together so this will be my
breakdown for marvel's what if episode 1
i'll talk about everything that you need
to know that happened in this episode
including all of the captain america
callbacks because this was essentially
captain america the first avenger with
just that one twist that one event that
changed the entire outcome for this
pocket universe and if you loved peggy
carter as captain carter we're actually
going to start off by talking about the
possibility of her actually appearing in
live-action form in the actual mcu now
what if even though animated actually
takes place inside of the mcu this has
been confirmed by people over at marvel
studios it just doesn't take place in
that main mcu sacred timeline these are
essentially branch timelines that we saw
in loki but like i mentioned if you
liked captain carter there have been
reports stating that she is going to
show up in the mcu in live action in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness these reports come from credible
sources like daniel rpk i also
interviewed the director brian andrews
and the head writer ac bradley for what
if and i actually asked them about this
i asked if peggy carter showing up in
the mcu in live action form is a
possibility and of course they couldn't
give me an answer but they both said
that they're very hopeful and they would
love to see that happen and not to
mention the executive producer brad
windebaum in the press conference pretty
much told us that yes these characters
can appear later on in the mcu in
live-action form and of course it's all
thanks to the multiverse essentially
anything is possible even an animated
character going into a live action
universe so if you love peggy carter it
looks like we could be getting more of
her as captain carter down the road in
live action form so if you'd like to
stay up to date on all mcu news be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and now we'll dive into
the breakdown of episode one now we
start off by hearing the voice of uwatu
the watcher and uatu isn't the only
watcher in fact there are watchers and
entire species of them and in the comics
they're known as the oldest species in
the universe in fact they're so ancient
that the original name for the race has
been forgotten so they call themselves
the watchers based off of the tasks that
they do watching the universe the
watchers are cosmic entities they are
extremely powerful and as our watcher
says at the end of episode 1 he watches
all but he does not and he cannot will
not interfere the watchers made this
rule because originally they actually
did interfere and try to help
civilizations however this eventually
led to some civilization's destruction
thanks to nuclear weapons so the
watchers simply watch and observe now
and it is their law that they cannot
interfere now uwatu actually does
interfere in the comics he's actually
very close with the fantastic four and
he helps them out eventually the
watchers would put him on trial and they
would eventually ban him however he
would continue to watch earth and was
eventually reinstated now our watcher
uatu in what if is voiced by jeffrey
wright and he states the premise in the
beginning he explains that time space
and reality aren't linear they're a
prism of endless possibilities in which
one choice can branch out into infinite
realities now as he says this the glass
kind of breaks and we actually get
little glimpses here of what's to come
in future what-if episodes i am lucky
enough to have seen the first three so i
actually do recognize a few of these in
the first glass that breaks we can see
doctor strange on the right below him we
can see tony stark eating a donut from
that iron man 2 scene to his left we can
actually see t'challa being picked up by
yondu to the left of that we see red
skull then yondu killmonger proxima
midnight which is going to come in the
next episode episode two then above them
we can actually see peggy carter getting
the serum above her we can see loki and
his troops and then right in the middle
there we can see raimonda the queen of
wakanda above her we can see black widow
and above her we can see steve rogers
then in the next glass all the way on
the right we can see karina who was the
slave to the collector and guardians of
the galaxy she pops up in episode 2. to
her left of course we see captain carter
below her doctor strange then to the
left it looks like shuri then we have
nick fury then we have t'challa right
before he's abducted that's next episode
as well above him is iron man and then
to the right we have t'chaka and what
looks to be killmonger now from here we
dive into what the episode is about and
to be quite frank this really is captain
america the first avenger except instead
of captain america it's captain carter
of course things don't go down exactly
how they went down in the movie they
threw some nice twists at us but the
premise is pretty much the same the nazi
army and red skull are marching across
europe and ultimately want to take over
the world while the rest of the allied
countries come together to make a super
soldier now we know how the original
version goes captain america the first
avenger he gets the super soldier serum
becomes captain america and essentially
ends the war however this is what if and
the what if is in the title of the
episode what if captain carter were the
first avenger now this jumps right into
when steve rogers is about to get the
super soldier serum and we meet dr
erskine and a military personnel that we
haven't seen in the first captain
america the first avenger movie however
agent carter fans will recognize this
person this is john flynn however in
this what if episode it's colonel john
flynn and he's actually modeled after
and voiced by the actor who played john
flynn in agent carter bradley whitford
and for the most part he pretty much is
the same character that he was in agent
carter a guy who doesn't really believe
that a woman can really do much when it
comes to war and if you look closely we
can also see colonel phillips on the
right who was played by tommy lee jones
now from here things get very different
erskine says that agent carter would
probably be more comfortable in the
booth and in the movie she agrees and
goes in the booth however things play
out a little bit differently in the
movie as when he originally asked her
this in captain america the first
avenger steve is already on the table
clearly not the same case here and not
to mention jon flynn is not there so
peggy refuses to go into the booth and
she stays in the room which is
apparently the moment that created a new
universe now from here again things play
out a little bit differently than in the
movie and what if the attack happens
before steve rogers gets the serum in
the movie it happens after so and what
if a hydra agent activates a bomb from
here the agent runs up and he actually
shoots colonel phillips this is
different from what happened originally
originally it was actually dr erskine
that got shot twice and this resulted in
his death but that doesn't happen in
what if and the gunman continues to run
towards steve steve runs at him and the
gunman shoots him two times he attempts
to steal the serum but peggy shoots him
and kills him but the program is already
activated they can't stop it so they
only have one chance to make a super
soldier colonel flynn tells howard stark
to get in there but howard says no
that's not who he is he's a scientist
and since steve is shot he can't go
through with it so of course peggy takes
the initiative and comes out a super
soldier and flynn is pissed and he
thinks they blew their only chance he
also says that the ssr is now under his
command which leads us to believe that
colonel phillips actually died we then
cut to a scene of peggy carter punching
a punching bag until she eventually
punches it off the chains and this is
pretty much the exact same scene that we
see at the very very end of captain
america the first avenger in the second
post-credits scene after steve rogers
was frozen for 70 years he is finally
alive in the real time to relieve some
stress he starts punching a punchy bag
just like peggy did until eventually he
punches it off the chains but and what
if it's peggy doing it and steve's alive
and standing right behind her then we
get a little bit of a meta joke here
steve says well it could be worse flynn
could stick you on one of those uso
tours where a crazy costume being told
to smile 10 times a day peggy says he
wouldn't he couldn't could he and steve
gives a little smirk because in another
universe in our main mcu timeline that's
what steve rogers did he literally went
on a uso tour wore a spangly outfit and
smiled 10 times a day so a little node
to the main timeline there then we have
another node to the main timeline steve
tells peggy i never was much of a dancer
anyways and she says maybe you haven't
found the right partner this is similar
to what she says in captain america the
first avenger when she's talking to
steve and bucky is standing beside her
she says after this is done i might go
dancing in which bucky replies what are
we waiting for and she says the right
partner so from here red skull gets the
tesseract in the same way he does in the
movie captain america the first avenger
peggy and the team find out that red
skull has it and that it's on its way to
berlin but colonel flynn doesn't want to
send anybody after it because he thinks
it's an over-glorified battery however
howard stark knows what it truly can do
and of course he decides to go behind
flynn's back but not before giving peggy
carter her vibranium captain carter
shield from here we see captain carter's
true abilities and it does seem like she
is pretty op now of course it's
animation which allows for a lot more
cooler things to take place and they do
a pretty amazing job the fight sequences
here are pretty fantastic and they did a
really good job at making them humorous
so captain carter kicks everybody's butt
gets the tesseract back and takes dr
zola hostage this is very different than
what happens in captain america and this
is where the whole what if scenario is
playing out very differently if agent
carter got the serum she would have
gotten the tess rec back which leads to
these upcoming events of steve rogers
piloting an ironman essentially powered
by the tesseract but not before agent
carter gets an upgrade to captain and so
she officially becomes captain carter
and from here a plan is hatched to go
save bucky but not before peggy says you
owe me a dance again bringing us back to
captain america the first avenger peggy
very casually runs up next to a
motorcycle knocks the guy off and takes
it and does some stunts that we wish we
could see live but are still pretty cool
in animation she breaks out the 107th
with ease and this time bucky has it
easy this time he's just in the prison
cell with the rest of the 107th but in
the movie he was actually being tortured
by zola captain carter busts them out
the door kicking open with her shield
mirroring the iconic scene from captain
america where he did the same thing once
they get out hydra ups their attacks a
little bit and peggy calls an air sport
in which unknown to her steve rogers
says he's inbound and he shows up in
what i'm going to call the very first
iron man suit what they call the hydra
stomper and this thing is powered by the
tesseract and this is something that
couldn't have happened in captain
america the first avenger because they
never got the tesseract this is
obviously a huge change from the main
sacred timeline it looks like peggy
carter becoming captain carter instead
of steve rogers becoming captain america
started the iron man suit with howard
stark and not tony stark and since
steve's new suit is powered by the
tesseract it is very very strong and him
and captain carter make waste of hydra
very very easily and there is a little
reference to the original captain
america here dugan says so a dame and a
flying buick okay and captain america
won the 107th escape dugan gets in an
enemy tank and he says that it's a
little different than a buick now from
here peggy steve and bucky start to take
down a lot of hydra squadrons and we get
a little montage here much like we got
in captain america the first avenger
when he does the same thing however in
this one steve rogers has the hydra
stomper and we get some pretty dang cool
scenes here of captain carter riding the
hydra stomper in the middle of the sky
jumping off of it destroying planes and
then jumping right back on now from here
red skull pretty much goes down the same
path getting away from hitler deeming
himself a god and above man meanwhile
peggy says that she loves a good whiskey
but she can't feel the side effects aka
get drunk because of the serum this is
also what steve said after he was
drinking after he lost bucky in captain
america peggy talks to steve about
finally being heard and respected steve
says he's still the skinny kid from
brooklyn now just in an iron suit but
peggy says that he's her hero and he
says the same about her they're about to
kiss when of course howard stark comes
out of nowhere and interrupts them we
then have many scenes that are actually
very similar to what happened in captain
america with a few twists on them we go
to the train scene where the 107th is
zip lighting down with peggy at front
steve goes to stop the train with the
hydra stomper the team lands on the
train but bucky slips and he almost
falls off just like he did in captain
america but peggy is there to catch him
he then makes a joke about how peggy
almost ripped his arm off which of
course is the arm that he actually loses
during the scene in the actual movie of
course it would then later get replaced
by metal and then ultimately vibranium
but it looks like if peggy carter goes
on to become captain carter bucky
actually never becomes the winter
soldier instead the train is actually a
trap and the person they end up losing
is steve at least so they think and a
lot of people thought that this would
have been a pretty good opportunity to
make steve the winter soldier and i do
agree that would have been cool but the
focus of this episode is captain carter
and here's where things start to get a
little bit different they have dr zola
captive and he tells peggy carter
everything and we find out that red
skull wants to use the tesseract to
unleash an interdimensional being that
will of course lead hydra to world
domination the 107th is in to go and
attack hydra for steve rogers and of
course to save the world captain carter
busts in the hydra base pretty easily
thanks to her super soldier serum bucky
and the rest of the 107th backing her up
until they eventually split up to go and
find red skull howard stark goes with
captain carter and here we have kind of
a funny scene howard stark asks which
way are we going captain carter says
that way in which howard replies should
we not have a plan peggy says who needs
a plan i have a shield and howard stark
says a shield is not a plan this is
basically a reverse situation of what
happens between captain america and tony
stark in the first avengers film except
the roles are actually reversed iron man
is about to jump out of the quinjet in
which captain america says we need a
plan of attack and tony says i have a
plan attack this is just reversed in our
case the stark is the reserved one that
wants to have a plan and the captain is
the one that says i have a shield i
don't need a plan very clever on
marvel's part however captain carter
rethinks the whole needing a plan aspect
when she sees that red skull summoned
with the tesseract what he refers to as
his hydra champion now this really does
seem to be schuma gorith we don't see an
eye but we do see the tentacles now some
people may think that this is a hydra
but hydras have heads a hydra is a sea
monster with multiple heads and when you
cut off one head more will grow back in
its place that's a typical hydra and it
doesn't have tentacles and shumagorth is
an interdimensional being which means
that in what if the tesseract could
definitely bring him into that universe
and it becomes very clear that hydra has
absolutely no control over it as it
immediately kills red skull meanwhile
bucky and the boys find steve and they
get him back into the hydra stomper
however it is no longer powered by the
tesseract so its energy isn't unlimited
and it was simply attached to a
generator to give it some power
meanwhile howard stark is trying to
reverse the portal however all of the
buttons are in german and he actually
makes a reference to a famous austrian
actress here hedy lamarr she was an
austrian-born american actress who
appeared in over 30 films since she's
austrian born he makes the joke that
they spend a weekend together but she
never taught him german but it is
established that howard stark much like
a son is a playboy now peggy ends up
picking up a sword which is kind of
interesting because hydra originally is
secretly running shield when they
eventually find that out and shield
disbands they start a sword so her
picking up a sword at hydra base could
be something that they're trying to do
here very meta if they are trying to do
it now howard eventually ends up
reversing the portal and the portal
starts to suck what i'm going to call
schumachorth back inside however its
tentacles latch on to the portal and
keep it from going all the way in peggy
starts to push the monster back in but
steve comes to save the day however
unfortunately the hydra stomper runs out
of energy and falls to the ground and we
basically get a reverse of what happens
in captain america instead of steve
having to put the plane inside of the
water we have peggy having to go through
the portal to stop the monster from
invading the planet but the dialogue is
pretty much the same steve says you owe
me a dance lesson just like he says i
have to take a rain check on that dance
in captain america in captain america
peggy carter says next saturday and in
this episode of what if peggy carter
says saturday night and then she's gone
and steve rogers is there left with the
tesseract however fast forward 70 years
instead of steve rogers being stuck in
the ice for 70 years peggy carter was
stuck inside of a different dimension
for 70 years just like a portal was
opened in the very first avengers film
and loki came out the same thing happens
here except peggy carter comes out and
it looks like time maybe didn't actually
go by wherever she was because tentacles
fly out right when she comes out and to
her it doesn't really seem like any time
has passed at all because the first
thing that she asks is where's steve
rogers and hawkeye actually recognizes
her he tells nick fury sir that's
captain carter nick fury says the war
ended almost 70 years ago and asked if
she's going to be okay and she says of
course we won the war and here we see
how one difference can change an entire
universe and we're gonna see all of
these different alternate universe
stories and what if season one and
season two so that's it for my episode
one breakdown of marvel's what if let me
know what you thought about this episode
do you like it do you like the animation
style or would you prefer them to stick
to just regular live action let me know
down below and don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos don't forget to follow me on
instagram and twitter if you want to
stay up to date on everything and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you